[Musique]
oh
il ya cinq ou six fresques sont des
jumeaux elle s'appelle t ne peut pas
leur couleur d'autres fins de mois où
les artistes ont connu voilà représenter
la nature et je pense aussi voilà notre
relation avec la nature et humide à
s'associer avec tout mon corps est où on
veut aussi mettre en relation avec la
note a obtenu 4 est comme mille peu
anciennes de par ce mouvement
on a eu beaucoup d'artistes comme bender
comme le cyclope
tous sont venus à versailles faire de
l'art de rue l'humour qu'on veut avec
vue c'est de pouvoir faire découvrir
autrement la nuit de leur talent
[Musique]
chaque fois qu'on a on fera le
commercialisation ou la peur avec un
site
on a à coeur de se renseigner
historiquement sur ce qui est présent et
de mettre en avant effectivement tous
les centres d'intérêts on peut être
[Musique]
oh